y para hablar de economía está con
nosotros jorge hurtado nuestro
periodista especializado jorge buenas
noches y empecemos con el anuncio de que
ucrania y moldavia ya son candidatas
para entrar a la unión europea para
aclararse de brindo ya oficialmente esta
aprobación unánime requerida para
otorgar el estatus de candidata a
ucrania y moldavia si apretamos la
política de los principales beneficios
de pertenecer a la unión europea son
económicos ya que dan acceso a un
mercado de 450 millones de consumidores
con libre circulación de mano de obra
bienes servicios y capital pero una de
las medidas que ucrania debe adoptar
para ser miembro del bloque es luchar
contra la corrupción para ingresar en la
unión europea los países deben cumplir
una serie de condiciones económicas y
políticas incluido el compromiso con el
estado derecho y principios democráticos
ucrania solicitó esta adhesión poco
menos de una semana después de que moscú
lo invadiera el 24 de febrero pasado y
nos vamos a eeuu porque el presidente de
la reserva federal dice que no se
descarta que las subidas de los tipos
aumentan el desempleo bueno powell habló
ante el comité de servicios financieros
de la baja de eeuu donde apuntó que
existe el riesgo de que el desempleo
suba respecto a lo que ha sido un nivel
históricamente bajo a mediados de este
mes la fed anunció una subida del tipo
de interés oficial de 0.75 puntos el
mayor aumento en 28 años y adelantó que
probablemente en julio se produzca otro
incremento de 75 o de 5 puntos básicos
para luchar contra la inflación powell
también explicó que la subida de los
tipos están diseñadas para reducir el
crecimiento a un nivel que sea más
sostenible en mayo pasado eeuu sumo 390
mil nuevos puestos de trabajo bajando
ligeramente de los más de 400 mil nuevos
empleos que se venían creando desde cada
mes durante el último año y en méxico
sigue subiendo la inflación y también en
los tipos de interés el banco de méxico-
conocido como bank 5 aceleró la subida
de tasas para contener la inflación el
emisor mexicano subió en 75 puntos la
tasa de interés a 7.75 por ciento de
advirtió de crecientes presiones
inflacionarias se trata del noveno
incremento consecutivo del precio del
dinero por parte del banco central
mexicano y la mayor desde el año 2008 el
dato se presentó el mismo día en que se
conoció que la tasa de la inflación
general en méxico incrementó durante la
primera quincena de junio y se ubicó en
7 88% es el mayor nivel desde enero del
año 2001 según datos del instituto
nacional de estadística y geografía el
banco también comunicó que es probable
que estos aumentos a los tipos de
interés continúen en las próximas
reuniones jorge y vámonos a ecuador
porque las protestas están afectando el
precio del combustible y es que la
petrolera estatal ecuatoriana
petroecuador ha dejado de producir cerca
del 40% del crudo de sus campos ubicados
en las provincias amazónicas de orellana
y sucumbíos la empresa dijo que ese
porcentaje equivalía hasta el miércoles
a una pérdida de acumulada de 451 mil
900 barriles de petróleo mientras que la
caída diaria en la producción de este
juego fue de casi 150 mil barriles
cuando antes rozaba los 400 mil barriles
al día según ellos hay 700 81 pozos
apagados y 31 torres de perforación
paralizadas precisamente por este tema
de las protestas
denunció que hay daños a la
infraestructura robos y sabotaje de
equipos entre otras acciones ocasionadas
por grupos externos a la empresa según
la estimación del gobierno ecuatoriano
la afectación de los ocho primeros días
de las protestas en la economía del país
alcanzó los 110 millones de dólares los
manifestantes exigen al gobierno reducir
los precios de los combustibles atender
el problema del desempleo regular e
incluso de los precios de los productos
del campo y combatir la delincuencia y
el reino unido- también hay protestas es
el segundo día de manifestaciones de los
empleados ferroviarios que está pasando
el primero fue este martes la huelga
obligó a cancelar alrededor del 80% de
los servicios las estaciones estaban
totalmente vacías hoy el tráfico ahí era
menor que el previsto porque al parecer
muchas personas tomaron el consejo de
evitar los viajes los ferroviarios
reclaman mejores salarios condiciones de
trabajo y estabilidad laboral el
sindicato ferroviario marítimo y de
transporte batalla contra 13 empresas
ferroviarias privadas y la estatal
national reid para el sábado habrá un
tercer paro como parte de la huelga más
grande en los últimos 30 años y cuál es
la cifra del día 300 300 despidos
realizo netflix en búsqueda de controlar
sus costos la mayoría de afectados se
encuentran en eeuu la compañía de
streaming enfrenta una grave crisis de
suscripción bueno ya veremos qué pasa
gracias jorge por toda la información y
ustedes sigan con nosotros en el debate
[Música]